first of all how did you pull this off
because the list of people on
this album is ridiculous does anybody
say no to you
first of all the answer the first
question how i pulled it off
um we got to give all praises the most
high you know saying god is the greatest
and god's hands was all on this album
you know what i'm saying
um and does anybody say no to me uh
no just question nah um
i i i i it don't be no because um when i
when i say that meaning is if it was a
note
we got to figure that out
it's not even about this this album
that's why i had to just think about
with that that question because
you know my whole career and my whole
life they said no to me
saying so you know if i listen to those
no's
i wouldn't be where i'm at right now
[Music]
[Music]
bringing nas and jay together two
legends
and listening to what they're talking
about
is the evolution of them as businessmen
and as you as a businessman how
important
is it now to move the message to
something that says
this is where you can go and this is
what you can get i mean you you just
said it perfect
because um that song is so inspiring
motivation
but so beautiful at the same time and
you know i'm you know
nas and jay-z are like two of my
favorite emcees
ever and to put them together and to
know what they've been through
and where they come from and what
they've been through and what they've
been through together to be able to make
this beautiful song to inspire
everybody you know you have to look at
this like man
you know this is what you call unity
coming together
but when you come together let's spread
the light and spread the love
and let's inspire you know those are
some of our leaders
that song in that video that's for the
culture
i'm saying at the same time is that's a
dream come true for me
but i know for also a lot of other
people too though
you i'm saying so you know it's a gift
to the world
and i just want to thank jay-z and nas
and to be able to get beehive
you know what i'm saying to sing
harmonies you're
saying and yeah and you know i mean it's
such a blessing man like
that's a dream come true for me man and
um you know i'm still taking it in
when did you finish this album cause
last week didn't you say you were 99
done that you weren't all all the way
done when did you finish
man cardi b came in like a michael
jordan
um but beat her yesterday
you know she got the track last minute
she barely had time to
and she wrote the most incredible track
and
it's an anthem it's called big paper
i want to thank her man for doing that
it was like the last song on the album
um that got recorded that that got done
yesterday
like i got this files like
2 3 afternoon you know saying east coast
time the album comes out at midnight
so i still gotta mix it and master it
and you know ingest it in the system
and that's a big process yeah but
everybody was freaking out how you gonna
make it on time and i said
easy god's hands is on this album
he got us hmm and it happened
did kanye really roll through the other
morning because 8 o'clock in the morning
8 o'clock in the morning kanye came by
when i was just
getting started with my album making my
album and
um he came by uh i got a knock on my
door my
my bedroom one of my people that work at
the house
on one of my team members knocking on
the door say yo cavett mr west is in
your backyard
huh um this is a true story so i go to
my backyard and he's eating
eggs scrambled eggs with um ketchup um
he asked my chef to make him and some
vegan bacon
and we was just kicking and catching the
vibe and catching up
he gave me a surprise visit
[Music]
he ended up going to my studio in my
house and we just ended up playing each
other music
he started playing his music i started
playing my music
and it was just a vibe i'm saying it was
just a vibe and like
you know i was grateful to be able to
have a great conversation with
him and um but at the same time hear
some of his music and
he heard some of my music and i just
wanted to share that with my fans
because
you know making my arms i want them to
be part of the process you're saying
of course the internet went crazy
because kanye had on his wedding ring
first of all god bless him and his
family
remember this was a while ago when i
said a while ago
like when i first started creating my
album right okay
and i was like you know just playing
them
song ideas i had and so this was a long
you know when i say
not too long ago many i said like this
was like
way before you know all that and um
sending my love to him and his family
and his group of kids and
you know i mean god bless him and his
whole family you know
yeah by the way um you were working so
hard on this album you missed a
a face time with the two justins is that
true no it's a true story i mean i can't
make it up they screenshotted it
it's crazy man to be blessed with justin
bieber and also justin timberlake
it's crazy because um justin bieber man
it's my brother i'm saying
um you're actually shooting the video of
the song that we got together with 21
savage we're shooting that
this week coming up and um just a
blessing to continue to work with him
you know i'm saying this is like
incredible then justin timberlake i've
known justin timberlake
since i was like before a teenager wow
yes i've known him that long um
and you know we always wanted to work
with each other we were just
waiting for that right moment in that
right time and you know i
i sent him something special and it
really touched his heart
you were saying and um you know the
message with that song
you know it's important to always be you
it's called just be and
you know you know just be you
always be you you i'm saying i know this
is putting you on the spot but do you
have a favorite on this album
man i'm gonna be honest with you man
this is uh
an album where i made sure every single
song and i'm not and i'm not even lying
to you
you know for me i made sure every song
was my favorite
but look work i put into this album
i know how you do it and look you got
you have the hits coming so
we're going to be listening this out for
months and months and months and
everybody will be like oh this is my
favorite and this is my favorite oh i
love this one
how many videos are you going to shoot
well right now i got like
nine in the can okay i got like nine in
the can
there's 14 songs on the album i got nine
in the can and i want to shoot them all
i want i want i i wanna give the whole
world
a video to every song if i can i'm
saying and um yeah
when i made the album i was taking my
time and even with the visuals
you know saying like we we i shot
two videos last night you know bringing
in the release i was on
on a video set i mean you can see my
eyes i didn't sleep yet you know what
i'm saying
um so you know it's just beautiful to be
able to
to give the fans a visual too with these
incredible artists that i work with and
and
so you can see you know not only hear
these
massive anthems but see it you know what
i mean and then like
my whole goal was you know to make music
forever and
and have the music played forever and
kylie calvin the title of the album is
my birth name
first and last name of shame and you
know in arabic cali means immortal
forever
i'm saying so fight it's a special
project
i'm saying my brothers this is something
that i really put my
everything into is your son an ep on
this one too
oh yeah both of them assad you know
executive produced the album both of
them
um they picked the covers they approve
the covers
they help me you know with the music um
and
you know assad is four and a half now so
it's like he is
really dialed in you know what i'm
saying i love what you do
as a musician as a businessman but most
of all i love what you do as a father
and to put your boys on the cover and
what does it mean to be able to share
all these experiences and share
this journey with your children your
sons
man it's the most beautifulest thing in
the world you know
on big up my queen nicole and my two
beautiful boys
that was with me um through this whole
album and through the whole journey of
making this album
and helped me bring it to light and they
were the inspiration
and they're always going to be the
inspiration and they're always going to
be the motivation
and that's who i do it for period
you